you're a hawkeye who the hell are you
some people have actually called me
the world's greatest archer
are you one of those people
hawkeye has been a part of the mcu since
back in 2011 when avengers hit the big
screen however it's taken 10 years for
the character to get his own standalone
project with the upcoming hawkeye show
premiering this week on disney plus
we're breaking down everything you need
to know to prepare yourself for some
explosive action-packed marvel madness
following a slew of small screen hits
such as juan division falcon and the
winter soldier and loki hawkeye will
follow the story of clint barton of
course played by jeremy renner after the
events of endgame where clint went
undercover as ronan and went on a bit of
a murderous streak until black widow
finds him and the avengers assemble to
defeat thanos the six-episode series
will introduce the beloved comic book
character kate bishop played by haley
steinfeld who follows in hawkeye's
footsteps and becomes his protege
eventually taking over as hawkeye
herself he's my partner
we're not partners or
friends slash partners i wouldn't really
describe us as friends
you know considering we've already seen
elijah eli bradley from falcon in the
winter soldier cassandra lang and
ant-man and kid loki and disney plus is
loki with the addition of kate bishop
this seems like they're hinting that
marvel is starting the formation of the
young avengers
in an interview with comicbook.com
steinfeld spoke about the possibility of
her character joining the young avengers
to which she said this i'm so grateful
to be a part of this show in this
universe and it's only the beginning
this show's not even out so i'm looking
forward to that day
the events of disney plus hawkeye all
occurs amidst the festive holiday season
when we spoke with jeremy renner and
haley steinfeld we just had to get their
thoughts on if hawkeye should be dubbed
a new christmas classic and here's what
they had to say i think it has a holiday
event sort of um
vibe to it for sure and then layered it
with a bunch of other things i'll let
you know come christmas now renner was
on fallon monday night to promote
hawkeye and although he didn't reveal
much he did confirm that the captain
america musical would be featured in an
early episode to which he then joked
about a potential real-life avengers
musical
could there be an actual avengers
musical in the works on broadway
[Laughter]
well
i'm not sure about that look i it was
actually the last scene that we shot in
the show it actually it got it you got
to see it it's quite a show it's really
good it is actually it's pretty pretty
dang good jeremy also played it coy
about the future of his character when
fallon asked if this would be his last
time playing hawkeye to which he
jokingly responded with who the series
will also bring back black widow's
sister elena who we last saw by her
sister's grave being told that clint was
the one responsible for black widow's
death which of course us marvel fans
know isn't the case at all elena is said
to appear in all six episodes so she
could either be the series main villain
or potentially an ally depending on how
things go
canadian actor alex ponovich is set to
appear in the show as well as a
character named ivan banionis in the
comics ivan is a mafia member who runs
into some trouble with clint another
character marvel fans are curious to
know if they'll make a return as kingpin
of course kingpin was the main villain
of marvel's daredevil tv series and fans
believe he'll be making a comeback as
disney plus as hawkeye will introduce
the character of ekko played by aqua cox
ekko is a young deaf girl whose father
was killed on kingpin's order thus
having fans believe he's set to make a
return but a big question that's on
everyone's mind is how hawkeye will add
to the already expanding marvel
cinematic universe past disney plus
shows such as juan division and loki saw
our heroes experience the start of the
multiverse shifting which is sure to be
a major topic in the upcoming spider-man
far from home and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness films however
thanks to marvel's shifted release dates
it seems like hawkeye is set before the
events of the multiverse cracking open
if anything we have a feeling the series
might follow a similar pattern to falcon
in the winter soldier where the torch
will be passed from one character to
another
hey look that one's you no it's katniss
everdeen let's go
problem is branding no my problem is you
so who are you most excited to see
return in hawkeye kingpin elena possibly
another avenger drop your thoughts in
the comments below
you